now to another example of Democrats not
on the same page of the political
playbook this happened earlier this week
in Washington and now the Democratic
leadership is trying to tighten up of
correspondent Peter Doocy picks up that
story in the house chamber Democrats
have more seats but in house committee
hearing about climate change
Democrats have left a lot of empty seats
so Republicans voted to shut it down the
motion passes the hearing is adjourned
and because only two Democrats showed up
is the party whose platform includes a
line that reads climate change poses a
real and urgent threat didn't get to
have a hearing about that real and
urgent threat got you tricked but it's a
cheap trick and will be prepared for the
new Democratic majorities strength was
shaken further when Republicans insisted
a gun background check bill needed
language about undocumented immigrants
buying guns and to speaker Pelosi's
dismay Republicans succeeded convincing
26 Democrats to join them in amending
the bill by voting YES No just vote no
because the fact is vote YES is to give
leverage to the other side now Democrats
are reportedly thinking of ways to limit
use of the tool Republicans used here
called a motion to recommit or MTR
changes to the MTR would be a nuclear
option Republicans have weaponized the
MTR to force vulnerable Democrats onto
the record on hot-button issues so a
spokesman for the National Republican
Congressional Committee chimed in quote
buckle up and grab your popcorn because
Democratic infighting is already
reaching a breaking point and it's only
month two of Democrats House Majority
just wait until the intra-party
primaries begin until then the GOP will
need to rely on loopholes to make their
mark but the next thing they try could
be squashed by the speaker the power of
the speaker is awesome but House
Democrats are still passing some
high-profile agenda items like the
resolution disapproving president
Trump's emergency declaration and a
public lands package so democratic
growing pains could be short-lived
but then again very few things they pass
there are ever going to get signed
by President Trump Brett Peter Doocy up
on the hill Peter thanks